when did you decide to start your
channel
i started the channel january of
2018 but i had been thinking about it
for about a year before
it was something that i knew that i
wanted to do
um it started out really i just wanted
to
like i wanted to show reel so that i
could get more work
and then i realized you need far more
work if you have your personality
blended in there
you know if people really get a sense of
knowing you they're gonna hire you
if they trust you if they know your
sense of humor if they know that
if the pressure is on you're not gonna
crack you're not gonna blow
your lid you're not gonna embarrass them
in front of clients you're gonna you're
gonna like just figure it out and get
the job done
they're gonna hire you nine times out of
ten you don't have to be the best you
don't have to have the best show reel
and so uh i looked at a youtube channel
as a way to like
infuse my work some cinematography
storytelling ability
my need to somehow like
validate all the years of acting and so
like
building these like imagine like
borderline fiction but somehow grounded
in truth
documentary style vlogs um
and blend the personality in there and
so that's what i
that's what the intention was all along
and now it's like two years into it i
kind of feel like
i'm not so much shooting in the dark now
i kind of understand what i'm doing
but if it it didn't start out that way
but that was the intention for sure what
was the first video that you made
uh the first video i did
was i think it was like five
camera hacks or something for traveling
filmmakers it was
it was supposed to be short and kind of
be
like a shot out of the canon of all
these things that you probably didn't
know you could do
like make your own media pass so you can
get discounts when you fly airlines
but it it feels a little foreign now
when i think about like what
i want with my channel it just feels
like it's a little out of place
and how much time did you spend editing
that one
first video oh god that first video
uh i actually shot it twice so i had
worked on that video
when i very first started the channel
um it was a year in the making so that
first video took me a year
to just get the nerve to figure it out
to shoot it
figure out what i wanted to say i shot
it i edited it
and then i sat on it for a couple of
months and then
about a year later i looked at it and i
was like this is crap and i re-shot it
again
and re-edited it so it was completely
new
and that was my first episode and
actually i think it was
that episode was not five camera hex
that story that you're talking about
is from i think it was like episode two
or three
it was uh building a youtube studio out
of my bedroom
yeah so that one
the funny thing is that my cousin
watched both versions and he couldn't
tell the difference so it was
like and i totally agree with him now
it's it's so ridiculous
uh having to reshoot and edit i mean
even though it's like
it's the same content it's the same
message it's the same
the same talking points you know just
but shooting it a little cleaner
what are your thoughts on having a
perfect video versus
just getting content out there you know
i i i don't know that i would recommend
anyone do what i'm doing because
i go against the grain so everyone it's
like
known rule of thumb that you just pump
out as much content as you can
you build that audience and you just
keep repeating what is successful
and you do it as fast as you can because
you want to build that momentum
and for me i want to look back at 10
years
and look at a body of work that stood
out on its own and i want to
have a set of skills that will transcend
above youtube and
all of that and so in order to do that
you have to do something a little
differently
and you have to basically put all your
energy into each video
and make them stand out and make them
make them interesting make them
something that
you're not doing for views but you're
doing because they were challenging
for you